breaking news at 11 the A's bill is in
and we're one big step closer to having
professional baseball right here in Las
Vegas thank you for joining us at 11 I'm
Brian Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez so it
is a late night in Carson City where
lawmakers introduce SB 509 joining us
now in studio to break down what we know
right now is our 8 news now investigator
Kyle Payne who's been following this for
weeks Kyle Denise it has been weeks in
the making but here we are the bill
paves the way for a 1.5 billion dollar
Stadium for the A's sounds like they
just dropped this bill it was first seen
tonight around 8 o'clock just yesterday
the Democratic Leadership and the
governor had strong words for each other
about the A's and the budget neither of
which seemed certain and the session
there ends on June 5th there was talk
maybe even about a summer session a few
more things we know about the build
they'll be looking for 380 million
dollars that will come from Public
Funding and tax credits the bill also
creates the Southern Nevada tourism
Innovation act that establishes the
method to finance the project we also
saw renderings today that showed the
ballpark they want to build they're here
behind me the 30 000 seat stadium is
proposed to be built on the site of the
Tropicana facing the strip Brian and
Kyle the A's are getting out of town
while the getting is good they've lost
almost every game this season and really
few fans are showing up they have the
worst attendance in the league the fans
that do go to the games are chanting
horrible things with the owner and at 10
and 43 they're up to the worst start in
120 years